décidément tout le monde du rap en veut
à genlis ya moi je n'aime pas jeudi
dernier l'homme politique était invité
sur notre plateau pour un débat face à
bubba sur ce genre musical
un débat qui n'a duré que quelques
petites secondes puisque vous barrent
envoyé gentiment jean-michel dans les
coulisses vous inviter les gens pour
qu'ils ferment leur gueule en euros mais
hier soir c'est un autre rappeur qui
s'en est pris à son tour à jean messia
dans une de ses chansons s'agit de
karine qui dans son titre au château
noir sorti hier soir n'a pas eu que des
mots tendres envers lui on connaissait
la rivalité boubacar ici il semblerait
qu'un troisième candidat et rejoint
l'octogone hier soir je reste coi les
ennemis de nos ennemis sont aussi nos
ennemis alors qu'harry s'insultent j'en
mets ça dans sa nouvelle chanson
etes-vous choqué il va falloir commencer
à s'écrire gens mais c'est bien écrit
mais thomas l'écrit jean mes chiens
président de l'institut apollon vous
venez tous les soirs un décidément tous
les soirs vous êtes au coeur de
l'actualité
hélas et obtient 10 qui vous insulte
etes-vous choqué regardez il ya quand
même six qui disent non et 3 qui
n'entame y voit ce qu est choqué bah
écoutez moi je suis choquée mais je suis
pas choqué que les autres ne le soit pas
et parce que parce qu'en fait il ya déjà
certaine haine qui sont admises et pas
d'autres mais magie n'est pas imaginable
et c'est ce qu'il a dit d'imaginer ou
non parce que ce type ait pas de ma
famille pour pouvoir me blesser mais
c'est encore une fois il est il est
démasqué en quelque sorte d'aider
l'équipe à 100 et je trouve ça anormal
que papa seulement ici mais de manière
générale les maharaja rutilant de la
lutte contre la haine qui n'ont que le
mot au pnn à la bouche
certaines n bizarrement ce mot n'est pas
prononcé ça devient de l'art ça devient
quelque chose de sympathique
on imagine un rappeur blanc qui
insulterait un type de la diversité mais
ça serait le tollé sur le plateau il
serait convoquée par la simple
arithmétique là rien là rien johnny
alors voilà ce qu'il dit je suis dans le
salon compte la cam
la pilule est rouge faut être mattrick
dans la matrix je baise le 666
illuminati les maçons et ceux qui
pactisent toujours bien p sa sacoche
remplie de mapeza tiers soit d'amnesia
sur un [ __ ] de maison fuck un jean
messia non mais vous trouvez que c'est
des paroles ça j'ai pas tout compris moi
si vous pouvez la mettre
autrefois on admirait un chanteur pour
eux pas pour ses cordes vocales
de l'avenir pour ses crottes vocale
[Applaudissements]
c'est ce que c'est ce que m'inspire le
texte affiché êtes choqués parce que
déjà je trouve qu'un problème de timing
pour carrie ce parce que son rival
malheureusement booba a eu un clash avec
jean bessière ya quelques jours et en
termes de technique c'est pas bon même
si la chanson est évidemment été écrite
avant ensuite sur le fond moi ça me
choque pas que des paroles violentes
dans le rap parce que c'est à prendre au
second degré après qu'on cite quelques
uns personnellement et qu'on la tacc
personnellement j'en médias ça reste un
être humain c'est un père de famille et
malheureusement il ya des gens je suis
sûr qu'ils vont vous menacez suite à ça
qu'ils vont prendre ses paroles au
premier degré donc ça ça me gêne un peu
donc oui ça me choque alors vous n'êtes
pas choqué non je suis pas choqué parce
que dans la culture en europe tout le
monde ensuite tout le monde sait ce
qu'on appelle des punchline si jamais
vous sentez vraiment viser à ce point là
et que vous êtes vraiment choqué de ça
on peut plus rien pour vous parce que il
ya énormément de par exemple et le pen
ils sont visés sur énormément de textes
énormément texte ils en font pas tout un
fromage mais c'est bien là c'est pas là
mais madame sais pas madame sais pas si
c'est pas ça la question
la question c'est que si tout le monde
était insulté et qu'on avait les mêmes
réactions pour tout le monde ça me
choquerait pas moi ce que ce que je
pointe du doigt la ce et les
indignations sélectives
c'est à dire que le gouvernement
emmanuel macron le premier ministre sont
capables d'appeler quelqu'un de la
diversité parce que il s'est fait ou se
payer par un policier ça d'accord mais
par contre moi j'attends toujours là le
moindre appel de tous les progressistes
et les humanistes qui nous gouvernent
pour me soutenir face à ce déferlement
de haine s'est couvert d'honneurs genre
vous êtes toujours dans le discours
politique les a prévenus mais non c'est
parce qu'on vous avez monté au créneau
bon il fait ce qu'il fallait on pouvait
faire des caricatures de mohammed c est
quand on est comme ça vous tombe dessus
vous êtes vous êtes à dire non mais si
bien dire je vous dis je déniche
porterait le nom vous dit vous dites
qu'en fait ça tombe toujours sur les
ondes du front national ou ex front
national et sur les enduits rassemblant
nationale etc etc en fait en fait on
syndic toujours contre eux cette
catégorie là et je pense que vous avez
tort parce qu'effectivement quand vous
montez offrir au créneau au fond et vous
avez raison
à propos des caricatures ça ne peut pas
être deux poids deux mesures non non ce
que je pense laissez-moi laissez-moi
répondre à ça il ya quelques semaines
quand vous receviez ici la porte parole
de générations identitaire thaïs des ce
qu'ils font elle a été malmenée par
l'ensemble des chroniqueurs pour avoir
osé dire qu'elle défendrait son gré
elle voulait se marier avec un homme
blanc mais je l'aimé mais par contre
quand on entend ces chansons où la haine
à l'état brut
la haine sexistes tablettes contre les
femmes la haine contre les minorités
sexuelles de manière générale sont
proférés avec les mots les plus crues là
vous avez aucune espèce de réaction ça
n'en est pas là moi ça vous choque pas
pardon quand vous étiez jeunes y avait
des berlinois qui sortait d d d d
horreur annonce à chançay pas il sortait
pas des noms mais c'est à dire trois
fois puisque vous aviez dit s'est écrié
noir et ben oui ma faim autrefois si
vous voulez les gens on disait qu'ils
avaient un bel organe d'accord et on
vous le dira un organe vocal aujourd'hui
la liche antec l'organe génital
d'abord c'est de la poésie urbaine à la
cour visiblement vous êtes hermétique
sur la famille
absolument non mais attendez urbaine
d'un artiste qui s'appelle eucaris ce
que vous voyez ne pas aimer mais qui a
fait une chanson et qui moussent site
dedans et il vous rend il vous rend
artistiquement ce que vous professez
proférées au quotidien m'ont fait d'y
remédier aux fesses et bah quand il me
dit que moi je diffuse la haine qui est
diffusé à eux diffusés
la critique c'est de la critique de vos
pensées indie folk j'ambitionne parce
qu'il n'est pas d'accord avait laissé
fonctionner de manière mais a brisé le
mot [ __ ] maison ne vous dérange pas
absolument le mot [ __ ] maison ne vous
dérange qui n'est pas totalement
corrélée à talons c'est le mot [ __ ] de
maison vous dérange
il n'est pas corrélé à jean messianisme
s'il est corrélé mais vous la regardez
c'est pas utilisé apprenez à lire sur
rooney
les onze premiers albums et cias et
d'enlacer dans la foulée aller dans la
foulée vous toucher les dividendes de ce
que vous clamez chaque jour sur les ce
que je clame qu'est-ce que je clame vous
clamez je dis moi j'ai ce que moi je dis
est ce que la vie vous a dit que la
france les juifs ni que les fans des
sujets des samoa exclusion vous êtes
gêné quand des artistes noirs pas du
tout l'argent kamba pèse 185 millions
d'euros
ça vous a bah oui parce que vous vous
qui les boba je voulais noir oui dit que
parce que vous ces balles à partir de
ces bases et l'idole de balle ou devant
laquelle le veau d'or devant lequel vous
vous leviez faire bovalo vous bah oui on
voit on voit votre niveau si vous
préférez des bonnes si votre compte
instagram
il est rempli de haine alors qu'est ce
que le témoin ce qui est scellé selon
manon mehldau les exemples être le
premier à parler ou les meilleurs
emplois il n'y a pas de compte instagram
on peut le mettre donner des exemples à
g et rempli de haine et d exiger qu'un
cauchemar j'ai rencontré car ici une
seule fois dans ma vie il était
tellement gentil par rapport à voir leur
santé et votre haine nom m'est donné
c'est moi qui lui ai dit c'est moi qui
n'y fait car il souhaite je le traite de
nec maison vous plaignez pour vous cite
sur une chanson mais à a soit il faut
pas donner leurs plateaux télé s'ils
voulaient pas qu'on parle de vous et
d'une mauvaise volonté les aujourd'hui
voulait pas qu'on parle de vous et moi
vous invite aussi le voilà désormais
c'est à vous et à une minute on l'invite
il exerce sur les méthodes et les
auraient pas là des plaintes parce que
là là je le dis aussi pour nous faut
arrêter de jouer les hypocrisies les
gens abidjan messianique vient pas tout
seul sur le plateau et parce qu'il a vu
de la lumière
arrêtez avec ça mais juste pour battre
campagne juste pour vous répondre madame
vous avez dit que mon compte instagram
était était rempli de haine je vous
signale que la haine en ligne est
interdite et que si mon compte instagram
avait été vraiment rempli de haine ils
auraient été censurés avec c'est très
difficile aujourd'hui servant à table je
vous attends
alors attendez je vous apprends quelque
chose qui va vous en boucher un coin
c'est qu'il exerça siège le conte est
pas mal le grossiste ici le compte de
aures aures le compte de booba est
censuré chez astana
puis diffusée elle fait hollande ou que
vous avez pu rien dire la même chose
avec beaucoup non non non avec des morts
c'est bon cela le kung fu bas est
censuré sur instagram est le mien qui
diffuse la haine mais celui qu'elles
sont sûres et voilà rien à voir avec ça
mais j'ai du mal à me positionner alors
évidemment là je suis double est ce
parce que certains rappeurs sont
coutumiers du fait on est d'accord
blanche l'insultent n'est pas la
solution sous à défaut d'avoir une vraie
plume avoir une vraie subtilité ça n'a
jamais aidé les choses donc je suis pas
choqué mais je suis attristé par ce
genre de texte n delphine toi tu est
choqué mais je suis hyper choqué et je
comprends pas là votre bienséance un peu
bizarre j'avais toi tu es choqué tout le
temps de tout tu dis que le rap c'est de
la poésie c'est de la prose je suis
désolé il ya le mot ned on n'a plus
droit de l'utiliser même les gâteaux les
têtes de nec ont appelé droit de dire ça
arrêtez de les défendre
alors jean messia je suivais jeu là tu
m'as tu vu remettre l'atuge trop bien
sûr ce que dit lapierre après je vais te
laisser finir et fine vous êtes
l'antipode de vitesse géniaux mais je
vous dis ça c'est sûr même ça ça là là
mais je vous le dit voilà je vous lis
pas ce que je vous dis la vérité vous
êtes un petit peu de vitesse parce que
ça aurait été quelqu'un d'autre aurait
fait ça vous auriez vous auriez crié au
scandale
vous faites que de dire que j'en ai
citées dans cette chanson il n'est pas
cités il est insulté dans cette chanson
et benjamin toi tu es sensible tu est
sensible à tout ça imagine dans une
chanson on dit fuck benjamin castaldi
fait rire dans des chalets avoir louis
moi je vais m'installer ici que justin
qui l'aiment pas moi je moi que ma soi
choquant peut-être lu ce qu'on peut pas
être un génie pour ces raisons et pas
pour d'autres a pas vraiment mais c'est
ça que je sais c'est ça que je veux dit
après jamais cherché je suis
parfaitement d'accord jean mas kastali
moi le fait qu'ils me cite moi ça me
donne ça m'empêche pas de nom mais ça
vous flatte qui me choque c'est
effectivement l'attitude des jdd gilles
verdez qui lorsque quelqu'un qui est
bien blancs bien français va dire la
même chose à quelqu'un qui est issu
d'une minorité
il va sautiller sur sa chaise comme un
cabri en disant au scandale aura six
mois ferme et le mais là quand c'était
quelqu'un de la minorité quelqu'un qui
est noir ou quelqu'un qui a ra il peut
dire tout ce qu'il veut insulter la
terre entière
gilbert
s et en apothéose le concept de [ __ ]
maison c'est pourquoi l'on parle de nec
médicaux de maison pourquoi cette
piétaille parle de neg de [ __ ] maison
pour une raison simple c'est torride
lines est qu en fait j'en ai arrêté à la
plage vous vous réveillez vous réveillez
avec le mot est là et un instant vous
étiez vous étiez complètement
chloroformé mais bon le mot [ __ ] maison
qu'est ce que ça signifie ça signifie
que quelqu'un qui est d'origine immigrée
d'accord a fait un parcours
d'assimilation est devenu français et
donc pour cette ce genre d'artiste et
ceux qui les suivent ceux qui deviennent
français les immigrés qui deviennent
français à l'image de la journaliste
claire coates qui est d'origine turque
par exemple qui elle aussi a subi les
foudres et bien ça devient des traîtres
ça devient les esclaves du nahd 2 des
blancs en quelque sorte des français
donc
et donc ils sont vitupérer vilipendé
voué aux gémonies
parce qu'ils ont eu le malheur de
devenir français or en france
l'immigration notamment celles qui
portent la nationalité française ça ne
choque pas qu'elle soit française
qu'elle ait une identité français en
quoi c'est trahir de devenir français je
vais vous montrer des choses
gilles verdez zenir si vous êtes choqués
ou pas regardez il ya pascal praud qui a
été insulté par le rappeur snoop si vous
l'avez vu ça où pas une balle du
cervelet regarder une balle dans le
cerveau les bleus sèment la terreur
nouveau qu'un coeur comme collabos les
journalistes sont ici cinq formateurs
campath
ça mérite une balle dans le cervelet le
canon de la bourse américaine est ce que
je vais dire moi car is nice et je le
dis chouly deux roues
c'est l'époque je les adore voilà c'est
vrai que j'aime beaucoup lorsqu'ils font
après gilles verdez que ça ça vous
choque ou pas et là il ya balle dans le
cervelet quand même attention c'est pas
la même chose non mais à la lagune
menace est là aussi
messieurs ne me choquera jamais et cyril
si je puis me permettre de vous répondre
juste en une seconde
vous dites quand ses jambes issia ça ne
vous indigne ou pas etc mais c'est parce
que ces gens missia que ça ne m'indigne
pas l'avoir parce que c'est lui bah
voila je le revends donc vous êtes à et
nous ne furent pas dû vous attisez là il
répond mais l'arrêt c'est vous qui
proposait deux apn vous êtes izella est
non tout ce que vous promet arrêté 12 et
damman vous êtes son père jugé bien vous
êtes en adoration de l'envié mais le
devant d'aider des remugles fétide que
vous appelez vous êtes vous et je vous
et vous attiser la haine vous vous vous
vous que vous me grimer vous me grimer
en quelqu'un d'extrême droite racistes
pour pouvoir décharger votre haine sur
en fait sur un une extrême droite
fantasmagorique
parce que si vous me dire que je défends
riad qualifié ce qu'est l'extrême droite
définissent et là c'est quoi l'extrême
droite c'est une manière d'exclure
beaucoup de gens qui sait pas ça les
fremm droit à un voyage parce que je
suis pas exclu la alors qu'orange est
souple et jean nicolas pernikoff ait
choqué je suis choquée parce que je
pense qu'on est dans une société où il
faut au quotidien et surtout aujourd'hui
surtout avec des gens comme jean bastien
dayer qui répondent à un vrai fond le
commerce sur certaines choses je vous
qu'un combat pour combattre l'ignorance
et s'affronter et dialoguer et je pense
que faire ça oui je vous défends là
dessus je trouve ça gratuit fassi a
défendu comme elle nous donne pas
mais pas identiques et je vais répondre
la même chose pour pascal praud c'est
d'ailleurs ce sont quand même des gens
qui ont une famille qui ont une vie
comme les autres et qui à un moment
donné de l'autre côté on a un bassin de
fans et de population qui pourrait
prendre le truc au premier degré alger
où ils vont devoir répondre les gens
est-ce qu'on vous répondent les rappeurs
joly eelv on est oui mais où tous les
jours sur leur plateau ils ont des
propos ton post invités l'est sur balles
en syrie lors c'est celle à 100 sa série
la grèce pour moi c'est facile c'est un
peu comme les réseaux sociaux vous
pouvez faire une petite attaque parce
que le soutien aux coded se porte alors
non ce que soutient au quotidien j'en ai
tiers je ne suis pas d'accord avec lui
il est toujours sur le même registre et
d'ailleurs vous avez bien vu pour sortir
de ça ils vous répondent oui mais alors
à linverse si vous aviez un blond qui
avait fait ça c'est toujours la même
histoire même passé rogers doit choquer
lui je vous dirais que comme c'est un
égocentrique un peu narcissique
c'est l'homme le plus drôle et vous le
citez dans une chanson vous êtes
bricoleur il a juste commenté je suis
sûr que ça vous flammes et bien sûr
jamais concédée à le bras les skis sont
agités comme c'est venu que j'ai fait
des études de psychologie on ne sait pas
sept ans de psychologie mais j'essaie de
vous comprendre sinon j'aurais peur non
non moi j'essaie de vous défendre
mais j'essaie mais est-ce que
mais si pascal et chad quelque chose
qu'il faut que je dise quand même qui
est très important la haine c'est pas
simplement d'être choqué c'est pas parce
que vous êtes choquée par des propos que
voulait qualifié de haineux la haine
elle est interdite c'est un terreau le
racisme est interdite l'antisémitisme
est interdite la xénophobie est
interdite donc si effectivement j'ai des
propos qui rendent dans ces catégories
là il vous est loisible d'aller porter
plainte contre moi et c'est la justice
avait la loi qui détermine qu'est ce
qu'on peut dire ou pas dire mais le
simple fait d'être choqués ne vous et ne
vous permet pas de dire que c'est du
racisme sur l'achat parce que si ça
l'était ben vous avez les tribunaux ont
porté plainte
juste vous vous êtes revenu sur la
semaine dernière la semaine dernière sur
le plateau atteint avec booba vous en
est pris directement au rap dans son
ensemble le style de musique qu'on
considérait comme étant nôtres la france
regardait donc voilà pourquoi vous
l'avez pas proposé n'est pas toléré de
racisme non mais moi alors le racing qui
dans vos chansons je le tolère pas
vraiment non quoi comme racine qui est
votée la haine anti-française la haine
entre les femmes la être la haine contre
les homosexuels ne détestaient
[Musique]
ça ça confirme ce que je pense c'est à
dire que le rap était est un champ de
haine on vient cyril hanouna comment est
ce que vous pouvez contester une telle
pas un tel propos
quand les quand les villes les femmes
sont qualifiés de pétasses depuis excusé
moi les générations
voilà